what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the idea of a residual plot
for a given regression and the data that
it's trying to explain
so right over here we have a fairly
simple least squares regression we're
trying to fit four
points and in previous videos we
actually came up with the equation of
this least squares regression line
what i'm going to do now is plot the
residuals for each of these points
so what is a residual well just as a
reminder your residual
for a given point is equal to the actual
minus the expected
so how do i make that tangible well
what's the residual for this point right
over here for this point here the actual
y when x equals one is one
but the expected when x equals one for
this least squares regression line two
point five times one minus two well
that's going to be point five
and so our residual is one minus 0.5
so we have a positive
we have a positive
0.5 residual
over for this point you have zero
residual the actual is the expected
for this point right over here the
actual when x equals 2 for y is 2 but
the expected is 3.
so our residual over here
once again the actual is y equals 2 when
x equals 2. the expected 2 times 2.5
minus 2 is 3 so this is going to be 2
minus 3 which equals a residual of
negative one
and then over here our residual our
actual when x equals three is six are
expected when x equals three is five
point five
so six minus five point five that is a
positive
0.5 so those are the residuals but how
do we plot it
well
we would
set up our axes let me do it right over
here
one
two
and three
and let's see the maximum residual here
is positive point five and then the
minimum one here is negative one so
let's see this could be
point five one
negative point five negative one so this
is negative one
this is positive one here and so when x
equals one what was the residual
well the actual was one expected was
zero point five
1 minus 0.5 is
0.5
so this right over here we can plot
right over here the residual is
0.5
when x equals 2 we actually have two
data points first i'll do this one
when
we have the point two comma three the
residual there is a zero
so for one of them the residual is zero
now for the other one the residual is
negative 1. let me do that in a
different color
for the other one the residual is
negative 1 so we would plot it right
over here
and then this last point the residual
is positive 0.5
so it is
just like that and so this thing that i
have just created where we're just
seeing for each x where we have a
corresponding point we plot the point
above or below the line based on the
residual this is called a residual plot
now one question is why do people even
go through the trouble of creating a
residual plot like this
the answer is regardless of whether the
regression line is upward sloping or
downward sloping this gives you a sense
of how good a fit it is and whether a
line is good at explaining the
relationship between the variables
the general idea is if you see the
points pretty evenly scattered or
randomly scattered above and below this
line you don't really discern any trend
here then
a line is probably a good model for the
data but if you do see some type of
trend if the residuals had an upward
trend like this or if they were curving
up and then curving down or they had a
downward trend then you might say hey
this line isn't a good fit and maybe we
would have to do a non-linear model
what are some examples of other residual
plots and let's try to analyze them a
bit
so right here you have a regression line
and its corresponding residual plot and
once again you see here the residual is
slightly positive the actual is slightly
above the line and you see it right over
there it's slightly positive this one's
even more positive you see it there but
like the example we just looked at it
looks like these residuals are pretty
evenly scattered above and below the
line there isn't any discernible trend
and so i would say that a linear model
here and in particular this regression
line is a good model for this data
but if we see something like this a
different picture emerges
when i look at just the residual plot
it doesn't look like they're evenly
scattered it looks like there's some
type of trend here i'm going down here
but then i'm going
back up when you see something like this
where on the residual plot you're going
below the x-axis and then above
then it might say hey a linear model
might not be appropriate maybe some type
of non-linear model some type of
non-linear curve might better fit the
data or the relationship between the y
and the x is non-linear
another way you could think about it is
when you have a lot of residuals that
are pretty far away from the x-axis in
the residual plot you would also say
this line isn't such a good fit if you
calculate the r value here it would only
be slightly positive but it would not be
close to 1.